[SOUND] All ready,
it is time for the third and
final opportunity to make
this blog look awesome.
Feel free to use the blog
that you've been working on.
Or if you want a fresh start,
you can download a clean version
in the downloadable section.
And just like before, I'm going to
give you some mandatory changes and
some optional changes for the blog.
As you set up in the first iteration
of the blog, the images right now
are basically just big enough so they
look good on large high DPI displays.
The good news is that you're guaranteed
to deliver high quality images
to everyone.
But the bad news is that these images
are probably too big for most devices.
There's also the added issue of artwork.
In that, when the view port is small,
users are seeing a wide image, and
they may miss some of
the most important elements.
Like for instance here on a phone
with a wide image of the horses,
they just look like dots.
You can't really make out any detail.
Enter the picture element.
For this part of the project, I want you
to use the picture element to deliver
different images based
on view port widths.
And for some images, like the horses,
I want you to display a different crop
of the image based on browser width.
So if the window gets small, crop it
in so we can actually see the horses.
It usually makes sense
to show tighter and
tighter crops of an image as
the browser gets smaller.
And remember,
you can use the source set attribute
to change which image is displayed
based on device pixel ratio.
Take advantage of this.
In this solution,
you'll see me set breakpoints at 500 and
750 pixels for my picture elements.
I'll also set up images for
1x and 2x displays when the browser
is larger than 750 pixels.
And just like the first time
you worked on the project,
I'm giving you a boilerplate
gruntfile to help you get started.
And once you're delivering fully
responsive images with picture element,
make sure to add some descriptive
alt tags if the images need them.
As an optional challenge, you can make
this blog look a little bit nicer.
In the solution,
you'll see me use the section tag
to separate pieces of content.
I'll add a new font from
Google Fonts as well, and
there might be a few other
aesthetic changes to the text.
So once you've used the picture tag
with srcset to deliver images based on
different browser widths and
display densities, and you've added
alt attributes to all of your images,
a code will appear on the screen.
Type that code in here to continue.
But hey, don't forget,
this is your baby and this is an art.
So try a new font and maybe style
the text just a little bit better.